as Democrats worked feverishly to
conceal the identity of the
whistleblower at the root of this
impeachment scam we've now learned
shocking new details about the genesis
of the Russia hoax well the Justice
Department Inspector General Mike
Horowitz reportedly has evidence that an
FBI lawyer somehow changed and
manipulated a key document that led to
the surveillance a former Trump campaign
adviser Carter Page who joins us now his
first appearance on fnc Carter do you
feel vindicated by this news it's more
of the same Laura these people keep
saying the same information we've known
about this hoax
for so long and all of the wrongdoing
and unfortunately it's it's just there's
been no real action to address these
issues so well it's it's positive but
it's not anything you know yeah amazing
so Carter the Washington Post actually
tried to downplay the Inspector
General's reported findings saying the
conduct did not affect the overall
validity of the surveillance application
according to US officials familiar with
the matter the person under scrutiny is
a low-level FBI lawyer who since been
forced out of the agency Carter to me it
sounded kind of like one of those
pre-emptive leaks so by the time the
report comes out and it'll have other
things in it too but they'll say oh
we've already covered that like it's all
water under the bridge now did that did
that surprise you to hear the Post
report on it this way again kind of you
know it's it's yeah it's not good but it
didn't really affect the validity of the
underlying warrant Laura I've seen this
coming a mile away these people I have
had zero input I have had Privacy Act of
1974 I know you've had Privacy Act
issues with things that have been done
against you you know related to these
Ukraine issues unfortunately I've had
zero information and they have this big
many hundreds of pages of a report and
I've had zero ability to review any of
it or ask
any Corrections and meanwhile all these
same people who apparently are leaking
are having all kinds of input so it's
you know it's just a complete disaster
yeah well the molar report everyone has
to remember what it stated about you
which people forget the investigation
did not establish that page coordinated
with the Russian government in its
efforts to interfere with the 2016
presidential election that should have
been the end of the story and I say to
every American watching tonight Carter
they see you tonight on TV but this
could happen to anyone if they can
target someone with zero basis based on
set up meetings and phony you know
saying hi to someone at a convention
suddenly that oh no you didn't tell us
the full truth about that they did this
to general Flynn and they tried to do it
to you and I'm telling you it sends
chills down my spine and it should
everyone else watching maybe maybe
people think I'm being hyperbolic here
but I am NOT well Laura I think you're
actually very much understating it right
it's not just they weren't just spying
on me they were spying with on all the
people I was talking with during the
Trump campaign during the Trump
transition and into the early months
through September apparently of 2017 so
all of my interactions with various
people they swept up all of that and
meanwhile you know as we again sought
today and those articles you cited you
know they're just dealing with their
friends in the media and undermining the
president and you were the conduit
obviously you were the way to get it
Trump I mean that's that's understood
yeah by the way the guy that the New
York Times is flagging there's their
theories that this guy Kevin Kline Smith
is the lawyer who altered the report and
so Kevin's clients of the former
low-level FBI were for altering the
email and he's not found but he's not
found politically bias actions by FBI
higher-ups but he was flagged before for
bias this same agent you know how deep
does this go you got one if a low-level
guy thinks he can do this he's not
getting signals from the higher-ups that
it's all it's kosher to
behave this way Laura this is just how
far we are from the truth right now
I had communications with mr. Klein
Smith in early of April 2017 when all of
these criminal leaks were happening and
you know all these people were trying to
undermine president Trump's
administration and telling him you know
the what the primary thing I was asking
for the FBI is to deal with all the
death threats that I'm getting and I I
flagged that for him and did nothing
yeah of course he did Carter I want to
thank you for being here tonight and I'm
really sorry what you've had to go
through financially the concerns of
course you have about your reputation is
everything so many people have been
unfairly targeted and it's like a police
state that was that was targeting
American citizens who were innocent to
try to get at President Trump or
candidate Trump and I just appreciate
the time you've taken tonight thanks so
much thank you